TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and this
is your very quick update
about the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Working together
as a community is
key to supporting
women in tech, which
is why we're excited to announce
the Women Techmakers Udacity
Scholarship.
This new scholarship provides
the opportunity for women
to earn online certification
in Android basics, Android
developer, front
end web developer,
and full stack developer.
All courses co-designed
by Google experts.
And includes opportunities for
women at multiple skill levels.
Head on over to the post
linked in the description
below to learn more, and
apply by June 9, 2017.
Cloud Source Repositories,
our hosted git version control
system, is now
generally available.
We've increased the
supported repository size
from one gigabyte
to 50 gigabytes,
which should give
your team plenty
of room for large projects.
And there's a new
pricing model, complete
with a robust free tier that
should allow many of you
to use it at no cost.
Get started with the post.
We've introduced two new ways
to harness the speed of AMP
to improve advertising
performance.
First, a new ad words
beta that lets you
use fast loading AMP
pages as the landing
pages for your search ads.
And second, we're speeding up
ads served across the Google
Display Network by using
the same technology that
makes AMP pages so fast.
Last week, at Google
Marketing Next,
we shared the next generation
of Ad Words, DoubleClick,
and Google Analytics
Tools, each of them
shaped by your
feedback, and built
to help you work as productively
and efficiently as possible.
For a roundup of the
updates, check out
the post linked in
the description below.
Please like and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this
week's episode of the Dev Show.
As always, if you liked the
show, please tell your friends,
like and share it.
Also, if you'd like to catch
some of our earlier episodes,
look right over here.